what is going on there citizens of
the reject nation greg here today john
how's it going i am great grand old time we are
going to have today with house of the dragon
episode 2 today ladies and gentlemen please
go ahead and leave a like that would be so
appreciated also subscribe click the
notification bell to get notified when
reactions for the next hotd is up gonna be aiming
to cover lotr as well the pg version of this
and the just as agreeable version two well guys
uh full length reaction watch along so we sync
up with your own copy the time code over at our
patreon page for super sexy rejects cover a bunch
of shows over there exclusively or the reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and the
team at prepper of course thank you for helping
us edit down these highlights let's get to it
oh it's that that crab guy they mentioned from
last the pirate yeah oh my god that is disgusting
it's yeah the screams alone if you've something
to discuss lord i want to know what is to be
done about my ships and my men the crown
will compensate you for your ship and crew
and make an offering to the men's i don't
want compensation i want my wife to be queen
i've sent 10 boys to pentos and volantis to see
if we might find common cause ships and men are at
the ready the step stones will be settled oh she's
strategy you have dragon right his father yes flex
that power i only meant that we should at least
perhaps there's some better use for the princess's
talents your grace get out of that chair son
of the steward of the lord of blackheath you
saw combat in the stormlands i fought for a year
as a foot soldier against the dornish incursions
i choose sir kristen cole he just happens to be
the best looking one too and uh you know he fought
against my brother in one so cut cousin my father
should be defended by a man who's normal combat
should he not of course princess let
us plant sir kristin's investiture
then i don't like how insanely logical
she is be more passionate and blind
over a thousand dragons a navy large
enough to span the seas of the world
the glory of old valyria will
never be seen again oh wow
foreshadowing yeah this guy's all foreshadowing
you do not mention our talks to renero do you
no you're grace
fear would limit our options moving forward
you know i find this is a way to be with my
mother i know it sounds foolish i don't think
it's foolish because i thought you might try
if not for me then perhaps for them i have
your queen i will not reflect on my dead mother
i like that shot a lot
i want him to see me as more than his little
girl my own father does not know the language
of girls either when i wish to talk with him
i know that i must make the effort thank you
they are going to become enemies just don't
tell me if i'm wrong just let us enjoy it
i fear that the eyes of our enemies are
presently fixed on the red keep a girl
has been named heir to the iron throne the
king's brother so disinherited has claimed
the targaryen seat on dragonstone and now a
foreign power has established a colony in our most
critical shipping lane he makes a lot of great
points seriously why isn't this guy higher up
our daughter elena unite the two
great surviving valyrian houses
with the targaryen dragons and the valarian fleet
bound in blood you can show the realm that the
crown's strongest days are ahead behind damn oh
boy it hasn't even been half a year since emma
passed the realm expects you to take a new
wife sooner or later grace come on alliston
yes
we should be free to speak
our minds to one another
you can say whatever you'd like you are the
can't hear king crickets yeah today at
small council paid no mind i i thought
i might have had some insights i'm young
but you will learn and there goes the
conversation another six months and do it again
maggots for treatment that's not ominous
whatsoever stop the advance of the rock
so it's not grayscale he proposed a marriage the
lady elena to combine the strength of our houses
and demonstrate my rain's strongest days are ahead
such matters must be discussed with a small
council that is what i'm doing presently
i uh dearly loved my own lady wife and to be
compelled to replace her for duty's sake you
are the king but i do not envy you you're clever
slime i love how subtle he is about these things
unite the houses
would be a great honor to join our houses
as they were in all valeria i would give you many
children of pure valerian blood so that we might
strengthen the royal line and the realm it's so
uncomfortable what your father told you to say
oh she improvised that she wants this more than
he does i understand the order of things i'm not
sure you do if you mean to elicit some anger from
me you should know that you're failing princess
quite the opposite i already love this scene the
men of the realm already had their opportunity to
appoint a ruling queen at the great council and
they denied it they denied you princess rhaenys
but they bent the knee to me and called me heir to
the throne do you remind your father's
men of that as you carry their cups
well played yeah battle of wits men
would sooner put the round to the torch
and see a woman ascend the iron
throne and your father is no fool
i i want more scenes with them i know
that was great do a bottle episode i'm
sure that she is good and kind and that
she will enjoy your company as i have
oh my god power move call this
a hail mary it's a new pinky
oh
very kind gesture allison very kind fictional
historical time period adjust your head correct
this relationship is appropriate for the time
snap oh jesus that's even worse the prince
left a missive which i believe might explain
it is the pleasure of damon
targaryen the prince of dragonstone
and rightful heir to the iron throne yep take a
second wife in the tradition of old valeria she
is to assume the title lady missouri no the prince
has invited you to his wedding your grace oh man
demon latest clever girls
i will go to dragonstone and
drag david back to place justice
damon is without limit let me go to dragonstone
she's let her go to dragonstone that was cool
they actually heard her out that's a good
question why didn't we think of that why do you
destroy yourself will you see the king tonight
if you wish it i've assembled 20 of
your best household guards my lord hand
i don't understand why you hurt yourself you've
seen the king right you better come back married
dragonstone
let's go
you're to relinquish the dragon's egg disband your
army and leave dragonstone by order of his grace
king where is the king i don't see him his grace
would never lower himself to entertain such a
mama's face oh boy even that guy knows so kristen
cole my prince ah yes apologies i couldn't recall
perhaps my prince recalls when
i knocked him off his horse
this is a truly pathetic show dave
with every breath you saw your name
your house and your brother's reign our
love does not know titles and traditions
such good attitude i know you've come for the egg
here it is uh-oh are you mad you've never
survived this well happily neither would you
to choose violence here is to declare
war against your king wonderful
even if it ends in the death of
your unborn child and its mother
i don't think we'll be fighting today
oh yeah
what's gonna happen all of
you see the [__] steel
oh oh oh jesus
dude oh netball chills
i'm digging it sorry
i thought i was pregnant this whole time
it's gonna be an awkward conversation
when i get back to the throne room
if you wish to be restored
as uh you'll need to kill me
so do it and be done with all this
bother you're more man than anyone here
damn think fast
well done princess
and that's how it's done
i mean there we were we were about to kill
each other and then she just showed up on a
track and it was awesome she was like
kill me now and he was like well fine
i'm taking the edges through the track
walked right back inside like a [__]
oh man that was unexpected yeah yeah it was
the first time in a while i was like i don't
know what's about to happen you're safe with me i
swear it you are targaryen you can afford to play
your stupid games with the king but i cannot
i didn't come into your service wanting gold
the power do you know who you're standing up
to you should wed lana velary on your grace
save lord call us and fix him at
your side permanently as an ally
god so many tough decisions i
know i feel bad from dragonstone
who else is undermining my authority actually
it could maybe be perceived that way your grace
you disobeyed me you deliberately
disobeyed me it's exactly the first thought
and retrieve the egg with our bloodshed a feat
i'm not sure so otto could have accomplished alone
i sometimes forget how alike you both were
oh i wish i had known better what
to say to you in the aftermath i
struggled to realize that my daughter
had so quickly become a woman grown
i could never replace your mother no
more than i intend to replace you as heir
oh and by marrying again i may begin
to ensure that we are better defended
you are the king and so your
first duty is to the realm
yeah yeah yeah
put a little stark love in the
targaryens in this show huh
some actual like actual warmth
warmth and compassion yeah
love and tenderness these are actual
humans they actually do love each other
and this is a complicated situation for
them yeah i have decided to take a new wife
this is a mislead i'm afraid
it could be i intend to marry
the lady allison hightower
what oh look at otto's face it worked oh my god my
house is valerian the greatest power in the realm
and i am your king look on error's face
when she realized it was about to be said
yeah what the shit's been going on
you what you and you and what
oh what a deceit
dude she's gonna go hang out with
damon now huh oh this is so complicated
i love it yeah that's what we wanted this is
so complicated torture these characters oh
david as valerian's origins reach back to old
valyria more ancient even than house targaryen
according to some texts oh my god he's talking
to damon he's we're talking to damon dude
i've always thought of you and i as having
been made from the same cloth oh god it is
oh yeah oh yeah oh so many nipple
chills this episode we're both men
who have had to cut our own way through
the world we've been passed over too often
now marry my daughter you've heard
of the troubles in the step steps
some mirish prince is feeding westerosi sailors
to the crabs i've been petitioning the king to
send my name oh but he's denied me and it
was never my brother's strongest trade what
being king
oh it's not wrong peter is backed by powerful
entities within the free cities
who wish to see westeros weakened
wow my house will be crippled i will
not have driftmark beggared while our
king idles himself with feasts and balls and
tornies i will speak of my brother as i wish
you will not
it must be made forged
i love the visuals on this crab guy yeah
oh wow things are moving fast i know
we're already a six-month jump i mean
when i say fast i'm not saying rushed don't know
moving out of they're getting to the point yeah
yeah i love it all right let's talk about
it yeah i love it good political soap opera
yeah right it's got both the elements
firing on all cylinders it's just that
constant percolating build of everything and just
i love watching [__] build it and to watch it
like just crumble i love the chaos
that you could feel is coming around
the corner i think like the great days of
game of thrones had always done that so well
and uh this show's like doing it just right off
the jump from the first episode into here alliance
is switching around like everything just gone
into disarray all because of this one thing with
the air and i i really love the ending reveal with
um cordless cordless cordless cordyceps cordyceps
cordless uh valerian equip corollarion with with
cordless because at the in the early part of this
episode it's like he's the one warning of a war
but he never thought that he'd be helping to bring
the war yeah he's like you're not gonna listen to
me then i'm just gonna go start it off myself yeah
headed that way anyway i think that's such a great
reveal and the alliance between him and damon
makes so much sense and you know with the way the
the first episode was moved at a bit of a faster
pace but i liked how this one was more deliberate
but really let you simmer in a lot of the tension
and let you really simmer in a lot of the
unspoken emotion a lot of the time there's
a lot of good visual language just working off
of the actors reactions to things yeah what's
going on internally and you could pick up on it
without them having to say it and i thought that
was so strong which so a lot was able to be more
powerfully communicated without it having to be
spoken and i think that is such a great testament
to the directing and the writing of this and of
course like god like with this cast oh my god
it's so phenomenal and the game of thrones was
so shitty before that yeah they were all bad
but none of them turned into iconic characters
and it never got better no no no one's name comes
to mind every time i hear the theme song i just
think that when you come into when you are um like
we're not we didn't read the book uh fire blood
and ice and in the name of the father the songs
of all that and stuff yeah we did we didn't read
it uh i mean got some information on it you know
just to kind of prep some mentality before going
into the show but i'm not like looking for
spoilers yeah a lot of things are specific
just give me some little history before watching
this and some reminders of game of thrones
um but what this show has succeeded at
so well just right away is and then saw
another ensemble show with a whole bunch
of characters i'm really interested in and
a lot i'm worried about and everyone's so
multi-layered like the the king uh viserys
yeah what a dumb move like for him to be like oh
i don't want to cause strain between you and my
daughter um and then i'm gonna throw in a random
bomb of not only that it's like it's your best
friend it's a total left turn and i'm taken now
as my stand to marry for love again even though
yeah all all this has been about not wanting to
replace his his lost love well i think the way
the targaryens have always sort of been painted
as you know especially the ones who are not as
involved with knowing like the true history of
of targaryens from the books and stuff is a way
a lot of it can be translated or interpreted
as you know like the very surface version i've
always known there's more to it than this but
the very surface version is kind of ruthless
horny people who do their own family yeah go mad
that's kind of with the interpretation of it and
you know even when they're talking there's
there's a lot of that coldness still present
because you know you gotta do work you gotta
do the politics you gotta do the king's duty
i think they do capture a lot more of that nuance
of of of emotion uh with these characters like
i loved the way they i think there was like
three scenes between the king and and uh renera
yeah i think about three and each one was
like them learning to talk to each other
yeah yeah and all the different things that
that are said at least individually in that
awkward space between them as they try to actually
connect and the things that yeah you like you can
see the road map of how all this goes wrong in
the silences between them and i think that's a
really compelling testament to both the actors
and the writing well i think that last scene was
so strong because i really did show you know in a
whole episode where one of the main focuses was we
got to find this guy king who's a queen who's he
going to marry and then you have this really sweet
moment of like oh that love that he had for
her because i didn't start to obviously he was
heartbroken and devastated by the loss of his
wife uh but it was nice to just be reminded of
okay yeah no they really he really did love her
yeah and it wasn't just some marriage out of duty
that he had to do like he that woman he really
loved and then to be manipulated into like he just
he's this guy with like a bunch of choices and
never knows which direction to take it's like
i'm gonna try to make the right one follow my
heart ah damn it and it doesn't always been
manipulated uh by this whole situation and it and
it's it's crazy like this fight for the throne and
yeah there's just so much going on yeah but what
i really i i the thing that was teased to me that
i'm really most looking forward to is the thing
with uh raineris uh rainis rainers rayness reigns
i can't quit uranus rhaenyra and reyna and rayness
they need to have more scenes together like i'm
excited to see how i feel like that you you
know we were anticipating some kind of you know
growing feud between them obviously because
the position reignus is in but now that you
know rhaenyra has been is slighted in this
way i feel like that could drive them together
well i think there's a maybe which
would make it even more um complex
you know if if her husband is like working
with damon and then she's talking to renera who
is obviously still loyal so the whole thing
is it's that good tug and pool of like duty
versus war my what i'm feeling yeah you know and
whether that be i don't agree with this position
this alliance or whatever it may be like rhaenyra
for example might be like [__] my dad um but
i'm not gonna go like side with damon try to kill
him but i don't know you know yeah like it's it's
all it's i like where it's weaving in and out but
specifically that relationship you know because uh
reynos has uh oh seriously wouldn't have heard
george r martin to kind of change up the name
get a full chart with faces just
like flash cards learn them all
um with uh with with uranus because she's someone
who has scorned and is so sad in her ways about
here's how it is and there's a lot of truth to
what she speaks because she has the experience
of not inheriting what should have been hers she
has the the knowledge and the in the wisdom and
the years and the pain of it all and then you got
someone like renera who's um you know while uh
somewhere ahead of her age and intelligent she's
still a little bit more uh optimistic that she
could make me make things a little bit different
you know so i think there's the things of
what she can inspire hopefulness of things that
could change of renera and then raynous who can
you know every once in a while and be like so
you've told japan i've lived through the sort
of political machinations of this world you have
to be like you shouldn't be surprised when the
world yeah bends you over a bit but also then yeah
rinera can be like but hey you know without all of
that baggage look what we could do you know see
i think there's a lot they could learn from each
other and a lot they could have fights about and
real debates about so i think there's a little
i think there's a lot of richness if done well
which that one scene with those two performers
it just demonstrated like man there's a lot of
great things that could come from just these two
interacting with each other absolutely so i love
that i mean every scene here i thought was like
this is like a tour de force of acting to me yeah
the the scene in the with the dragon stone and
like that was the center piece of the episode like
that you wait to see damon till that moment yeah
and i and i'm so excited to see how they continue
to develop him because the person he shows up as
in you know in public when dealing with the king
or the king's you know small table people like
he's he's one version and then when you see him
in private he's a different guy and i really loved
their meeting on the bridge and the way she's just
like giving him the opportunity right there and i
mean you know it's there obviously like there's
that family tie that's going to make things more
complicated but i love what is under the surface
of matt smith's performance too because yeah you
see all the wheels turning and you can tell that
maybe even though at this moment they have so many
reasons to be divided i feel like there's some
kind of unlikely i don't know if it's a union
but i feel like there may be some unlikely
harmony between rhaenyra and damon to come
maybe i mean i like your point what you're
saying because the first episode is you the
way you capture damon is the per is through the
perspective of how people see him and then this
one allowed for a little bit more private intimate
moments and perhaps some of the more deeper sides
that even reiner could pick up on about him you
know i could see that he is there he is just
a hurt boy yeah like he is a hurt violent boy
but he's still a little bit more into the the the
system at hand like i love that bit with corliss
where he's like i can talk all the [__] i want
about the king but you can't yeah yeah exactly
like that's not something i would have necessarily
expected based off the first episode i i i think
that's really well fleshed out and and the way
the way otto is like risa fonz has always been
great yeah ever since the nodding hill days uh
he's always been great but the way these layers
just get peeled back from him because whenever
he's put in a position i really noticed this
about his performance especially in this episode
whenever he's put in a position where he has to
argue or there might be a conflict of interest
amongst council he kind of the body language
and his tone of voice becomes a little bit meek
yeah you know like i'm like it's like it doesn't
really seem like you'd be the strongest guy
i don't want to speak out of here yeah
he takes it on it feels so natural like
you're a bit of a wimp aren't you like it's that's
what seemed so endearing about him in that first
episode what made him like so likable they're
like oh there's a nice one on the team but then
you see that you know he's actually like the most
strings up there yeah one that's the thing too
absolutely and that's the most gratifying
thing across these two episodes thus far is
is like it does feel a bit faster paced like you
said but it also feels like a return to the form
of yeah like the the scenes where certain
characters are meeting and the tension that
comes out of that and the debates and the all the
different political considerations you know that
stuff is all as thrilling as when dragons show
up at dragonstone and so yeah and uh and yeah
with hudo hightower it's like that only you know
we're two episodes in but that doesn't feel rusty
to me that that you would have the seed planted
and you would watch this machination you get the
knowledge that okay we're six months ahead now
and clearly that seed he planted with allison
is working because yeah now he's uh for the moment
gonna join their two houses and that could have
felt rushed and it it feels more like a punch
here you know take advantage of the man's grief
yeah i really prayed on that it's really smart you
learn a lot yeah man if there's one thing game of
thrones is great at is giving you uh characters
to add to the if you idolize this guy you're
missing the point how to be horrible and influence
people but effectively yeah that's a good that's
that's all i i mean who plays renara because she's
phenomenal yeah that's millie alcock right now i
i guess they're i can only assume we're gonna get
some sort of time jump well i love that this does
feel like chapters that unfold like every episode
feels you call it like chapter one chapter two and
and and with her even at the very beginning not
speaking up i mean trying to speak up and just
being shunned and being like if we can find
a guard you're just something less than um
but sometimes it does feel like you she is so
much more logical than everyone else i know why
wouldn't you want to get a guy who's fought in
battle yeah like that just makes sense doesn't it
that should be your first question
for solid consensus i don't know why
they got the requirements yeah yeah and even her
being like maybe we should show just a display
of power using our dragons or something to you
know at least force these pirates to maybe take
us a little bit seriously and i love that you
know i guess to kind of stand in for instead
of the looming threat of white walkers
you have the looming threat of this like
feral pirate gang who's like leaving
people out to be eaten by crabs crab crab
that's the next one i'm going to have to commit
to memory crap battle i just keep calling him crap
it's nice i remember they talked about him in last
episode i was like oh yeah like a cool character
but then the way you see him does
does evoke a little bit more of that
um like a more messed up pirates of the character
right yeah when you're in davey jones locker yeah
like oh this is the r-rated version of what gore
verbinski probably would want to do like the
really messed up high visual effects budget um but
if it feels so grimy and an ugly yet you want to
you want to keep watching and it's i want to see
more of this twisted icky nautical body horror
stuff it looks awesome it's cool to look at it's
really cool to look at and you're like okay uh uh
corliss wants you know to fight but maybe it'll
lead to an alliance like when they think oh with
the pirates yeah oh maybe yeah i mean if if they
they speak the language of the sea together so i'm
sure that and i bat pirates would probably
have a reason to be vexed about dragons so
i don't know i mean i just love a show that
feels so cold yet so goddamn heartbreaking
i love a show that can do both at the same time
because yeah like this everyone's so layered and
and it seems like ronero is like the only good
person the only one well that's the only i feel
like i'm missing someone here is like the only
good person well that's the thing is raniera
seems like the only good person who also is at
least smart and cunning enough about the world she
lives in whereas like i feel like king viserys is
a good guy and he's the one where i'm like you're
just too nice a guy for the you're not cut out for
this world more like uh you're making some choices
i don't really agree with but yeah i get it though
like i get it yeah no it's not yeah it's not bad
i feel like they gave a little bit of a stark
touch to them yeah exactly like allison's not
bad i guess there's more well no she's in a rough
position yeah you can see so much conflict coming
out of that but yeah she's not connected there's
a lot of good people yeah yeah there's a cluster
of good people kristen sir kristen seems
like an all right guy yeah you know i mean
but hands down whenever matt smith is on the
screen he just he really just steals the show
finally they got him to like a true project
worthy of his talents such an antithesis yeah
right yeah the exact opposite of character it's
like he does the things you like about matt smith
but in the most icky like i don't trust this guy
at all kind of package yeah what horrific thing
is he gonna do next week because he's phenomenal
whenever he's on screen and i do like because you
like to see him relish but i love when you
do get more of those quieter moments where
he's just observing and you're watching them
so i really love that little wind and ruffin
touch where you're like they're not
talking but i know what they're thinking
yeah now let's get let's get a synth score
in the next episode slow motion walking away
with the trout at the track the dragon
um reveals because i think i feel like
we're gonna get like a cool battle next
week there's gotta be yeah i think next
week's gonna be a [__] in battle it's gonna
be really hard to keep this video montage
the thing with the dragons uh oh yeah i thought
that was handled so well at dragonstone where
you it's like okay is that is that damon's dragon
coming up oh she's just gonna try like unleash
fire on them and then for her the way they
handled the reveal that it was her on there
oh that was coming through the clouds like
jaws i like when they choose to speak valerian
yes the choice of that always feels very apt
very deliberate yeah it's great great moments
to choose when it's speaking it's it's
always like this is real talk right now
yeah yeah we're not the common folks should be
privy to this conversation yeah i'm gonna do it
in the ancient times never a real conversation
yeah this is for adults like when you hear
like all my latino friends when they start
like yelling at each other in spanish
yeah um well they're good and they're good
at selling it like it's like they really
understand the language too yeah i'm
like i don't know it but it sounds cool
yeah it sounds like they really learned it maybe
um everything about this is is awesome there's a
lot of great things to come and and i feel like
next week's gonna be a banger oh yeah like that
one's gonna have some real violence some hardcore
yeah some some nautical and some fiery violence
and the last thing i'll say is like would
damon and uh and uh uh the horror uh
yes we got the names filled up
here yeah and damon and miseria
like even her speech i was very much touched by
and that's just another thing that drives home the
whole thing that would him and auto and otto um
cordless we're talking about because the
king got to marry someone he loves lost
her and he still gets to choose yeah who he
wants for remarriage and damon is just like
stuck with a woman he clearly does not like yeah
and he can't even ha he can't even just have her
yeah you could see that while he was being
very manipulative on a lot of many accounts
and using her there is that thing that seems
like he actually does like her and at the
end of the day if you were to choose who to
marry it'd be her yeah i mean you see that
dual life of like no they have a real bond he
actually cares about what she has to say but
also he's clearly entwined in the game of thrones
and and i like that this show the books i'm sure
like these stories bothered to give credence to
characters like that because i thought her speech
was really great and she's like yeah i don't
i don't care about like statecraft and power i
just don't want to be afraid anymore i don't want
to be used for everybody else's means like that's
the furthest reason from why i decided to be with
you and even that even that little brief thing
especially on the heels of a love scene that
people didn't seem very pleased by last week
i i like that they got some good emotional sparks
this week but yeah guys thank you so much for
being here uh this is uh an awesome awesome
show uh you can check us out on patreon thank
you to helix for sponsoring this video be sure to
leave a like subscribe and hey let's do a patreon
lord brian of house perry how's it going buddy
just wanted to wish you well winter has come for
me as you can see by the the the snowy backdrop
of bleak uncaring coldness but you my friend
you are the warmth in the realm the warmth
the realm needs my friend you no one but you
you brian perry will bring peace between the
realms you will unite the houses you will
be the king in the north and on the iron throne
the king of the entire realm brian perry but
only if you stay pledged this is the wall our
patreon that separates us from the outside world
from the people who wish to destroy us brian
people seek to see our downfall but not you
you're the best buddy i hope you're
doing well and we'll talk soon